OK, this isn't news to anybody. Our country is profoundly, cataclysmically divided, disagreeing about so many basic things-- the COVID vaccine, was the last election stolen, was January 6 an insurrection, or as they called it on Tucker Carlson's show, a grandma selfie party? It's two different visions of reality that seem doomed to never reconcile.
好吧，这对任何人来说都不是什么新闻。我们的国家正处于深刻且灾难性的分裂之中，在许多基本问题上存在严重分歧——新冠疫苗、上次大选是否被窃取、1月6日事件是一场叛乱，还是像塔克·卡尔森节目中所说的那样，是一场“祖母自拍派对”？这两种截然不同的现实愿景似乎注定永远无法达成和解。
[BREATHING DEEPLY] And maybe this is an inappropriate comparison, but somehow, this comes to mind for me. You know that thing in your personal life where you get into a serious fight with somebody who you really care about? And they see it one way, and you see it another way, and you're not seeing eye to eye.
[深呼吸] 也许这个类比不太恰当，但我不知怎么就想到了这一点。你知道在你个人生活中，当你与你在乎的人发生严重争执时会怎样吗？他们从一个角度看，你从另一个角度看，你们无法达成共识。
The best outcome, the thing you hope for, is that by talking it through and really listening to each other and trying to sort it out, in the end, you'll either see it the same way, you'll have the same story, or-- this is almost as good-- you won't agree on what happened, but at least you'll get where the other person's coming from and they'll get where you're coming from. And neither of you thinks the other is crazy or has ill intent.
最好的结果，也是你所希望的，是通过沟通，真正倾听对方，努力解决问题，最终你们要么以同样的方式看待事物，拥有共同的叙述，要么——这几乎同样好——你们对所发生的事情看法不一，但至少你能理解对方的立场，对方也能理解你的立场。你们谁也不会认为对方是疯子或心怀恶意。
I just wish we could do that with our politics. I understand all the reasons why that's not happening. I understand how some people think we're way beyond that. It's impossible, counterproductive, just a bad idea. But just to say, I wish. I think lots of us wish that. Without that-- and divided so evenly, nobody can predict the outcome of a presidential election-- without that, how are we going to keep functioning as a country?
我只是希望我们在政治上也能做到这一点。我明白为什么这行不通的所有原因。我明白有些人认为我们已经远远超出了那个阶段。这不可能，适得其反，简直是个馊主意。但我只想说，我希望如此。我想我们很多人都希望这样。如果没有这一点——而且由于分裂如此均匀，没人能预测总统大选的结果——没有这一点，我们作为国家将如何继续运作？
But who is trying to bridge that gap between red America and blue America and bring us to a common story? I honestly can't name a half dozen people if I try. And so whenever I hear of anybody attempting to do anything like that and doing what seems like a decent job of it, I perk up.
但是，有谁在努力弥合红州美国和蓝州美国之间的鸿沟，并引领我们走向一个共同的叙述呢？老实说，如果让我试着列举，我连半打都数不出来。所以每当我听说有人试图做类似的事情，而且似乎做得还不错时，我都会振作起来。
And I heard about somebody like that recently from somebody who used to work here at our show, Brian Reed. They did a story on this new podcast that he started with another former This American Life producer, Robyn Semien. Robyn produces the show. Brian hosts it. And they did a story about somebody doing this.
最近，我从我们节目的前员工布莱恩·里德那里听说了一个这样的人。他们报道了这个新播客的故事，这是他与另一位前《美国生活》制作人罗宾·塞米恩共同创办的。罗宾制作节目，布莱恩担任主持。他们做了一个关于有人在做这件事的故事。
And Brian knows how I have kind of a bee in my bonnet about this particular thing, and so he sent me a copy. And I am very excited to present a version of their story for you right now because it gave me a glimpse, a very tentative, first step kind of glimpse-- and I know that's a mixed metaphor, but just, whatever-- a first step glimpse of the possibility that people in this country could listen to each other a little bit and look at the facts of something together and understand each other just maybe a little smudge better.
布莱恩知道我对这件事有点耿耿于怀，所以他给我发了一份副本。我现在非常兴奋地为您呈现他们故事的一个版本，因为它让我瞥见了一种可能性——一种非常初步的、第一步式的瞥见——我知道这是一个混合的比喻，但不管怎样——一种第一步的瞥见，即这个国家的人们可以互相倾听一点，一起审视某件事的事实，并至少比现在稍微理解对方一点点。
We have some other stories in today's program. They're about couples managing their feelings during this heightened political moment, on the verge of all of us getting one president or another, one future or another. We're going to get to all that after the break. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们在今天的节目中还有其他故事。它们是关于夫妻在这一高度紧张的政治时刻如何管理自己的感受，在我们要么迎来一位总统要么迎来另一位、要么走向一种未来要么走向另一种未来的边缘。休息过后，我们将讨论所有这些。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
It's This American Life. Act One, A Tiny Thing That Gives Me Hope. OK, so like I said before the break, this is a story about somebody trying to bridge the gap in the way that red America and blue America see the world. And like I said, it comes from this new podcast that Brian Reed is hosting called Question Everything.
这是《美国生活》。第一幕，一件带给我希望的小事。好的，正如我在休息前所说，这是一个关于某人试图弥合红州美国和蓝州美国看待世界方式差异的故事。正如我所说，它来自布莱恩·里德主持的新播客《质疑一切》。
It's a podcast about journalism. And the person trying to bridge the gap between the two Americas in this story is a journalist. In the story that they did on the podcast, they get to that guy in a little bit. But the story starts with a couple, Dick and Emily, who found themselves unhappily living on opposite sides of the red-blue divide. When they first met, decades ago, he was a Republican. She was, she says, a bleeding heart liberal, but it wasn't a big deal. Then that changed. Here's Brian with one of the producers of Question Everything, Zach St. Louis.
这是一个关于新闻业的播客。在这个故事中试图弥合两个美国之间鸿沟的人是一位记者。在他们播客所做的报道中，他们稍后会提到那个人。但故事是从一对夫妻——迪克和艾米丽开始的，他们发现自己不幸地生活在红蓝鸿沟的两端。几十年前他们刚认识时，他是共和党人。她说她是那种“同情心泛滥的自由派”，但这没什么大不了的。然后情况变了。这是布莱恩和《质疑一切》的制作人之一扎克·圣路易斯带来的报道。
So, Zach, you're the one who's gotten to know Dick and Emily, this couple that was fighting over the news, right?
扎克，你是一直在了解迪克和艾米丽的那个人，就是那对因为新闻而吵架的夫妻，对吧？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, so their names are Richard and Emily Newton. He obviously goes by Dick. They're in their 70s. They just celebrated their 24th wedding anniversary. It's a second marriage for both of them. They fell in love singing hymns together in the choir at church. She's an alto. He's a bass.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，他们叫理查德·牛顿和艾米丽·牛顿。他显然叫迪克。他们七十多岁了。他们刚刚庆祝了结婚24周年纪念日。这是他们两人的第二次婚姻。他们是在教堂唱诗班一起唱圣歌时坠入爱河的。她是女低音，他是男低音。
That's sweet. Where do they live?
真甜。他们住在哪儿？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: They live in Orange County, California.
扎克·圣路易斯：他们住在加利福尼亚州的奥兰治县。
OK.
好的。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: And over the last several years, they've found that they've been growing more and more miserable over something that seems so basic, which is what news they would each want to read in the morning.
扎克·圣路易斯：过去几年里，他们发现自己因为一件看似非常基本的事情而变得越来越痛苦，那就是他们每天早上各自想看什么样的新闻。
We get up and get a cup of coffee. And we sit down, and we start going through our emails. And we sit next to each other when we're doing that. I'd say, Emily, I have an article here. Would you be interested in me sending it to you? And she would say, who's it from? And if I said "Breetbert" News or--
我们会起床煮杯咖啡，然后坐下来查看邮件。我们做这些事时会坐在一起。我会说：“艾米丽，我这儿有篇文章，你有兴趣让我转发给你吗？”而她会说：“是谁写的？”如果我说“布赖特巴特新闻”或者——
(INTERVIEWER) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Breitbart? Is that what you mean?
扎克·圣路易斯：布赖特巴特（Breitbart）？你是说这个吗？
Breitbart, that's it. Yeah, Breitbart. Or Epoch Times. She knew those were really right-leaning and wasn't really interested. I was the same way with her if she found something on Atlantic or New York Times or Washington Post.
对，布赖特巴特。或者《大纪元时报》。她知道那些是极右翼的，所以不太感兴趣。如果她在《大西洋月刊》、《纽约时报》或《华盛顿邮报》上发现什么东西，我也会这样。
Dick doesn't trust anything, no matter what it is, that comes from The New York Times, The Washington Post.
迪克不相信任何来自《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》的东西，无论那是什么。
The Atlantic.
《大西洋月刊》。
MSNBC.
MSNBC。
CNN. That's another one.
CNN。这也是一个。
CNN is another one.
CNN是另一个。
It doesn't matter what they're saying. He just automatically dismisses--
不管他们说什么，他都自动予以驳斥——
Well, they've developed their own reputation.
嗯，他们确实已经形成了自己的名声。
OK. I realized, we are not reading from the same hymnal here.
好吧。我意识到，我们在这一块儿根本不是在唱同一本圣歌集。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So they told me that they started arguing a lot more when Trump came on the political scene. Dick supported Trump. Emily furiously did not. But then it was after Election Day in 2020 when they had one of their biggest disagreements.
扎克·圣路易斯：所以他们告诉我，当特朗普出现在政治舞台上时，他们开始吵得更厉害了。迪克支持特朗普。艾米丽坚决反对。但后来是2020年大选日之后，他们发生了最大的分歧之一。
From the beginning, I never believed that the election was fraudulently stolen. I have more faith in people and in our democracy. Dick was more open to doubt.
从一开始，我就从不相信选举是被舞弊窃取的。我对人民和我们的民主制度更有信心。迪克则更容易产生怀疑。
They were saying that there was a lot of things that were going on that shouldn't have been going on. There was packing drop boxes with ballots. One person would walk up to the ballot box and drop in all kinds of ballots into it.
他们当时说有很多不该发生的事情正在发生。比如有人往投票箱里塞选票。一个人走上前，往箱子里塞入各种各样的选票。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So this particular theory Dick's talking about, it's from a movie, one of the many sources that he was turning to at the time. It's called 2,000 Mules. Have you heard of it?
扎克·圣路易斯：所以迪克提到的这个特殊理论，来自于一部电影，这是他当时求助的众多来源之一。它叫《2000只骡子》。你听说过吗？
I've heard of it. Yes, I've had people talk to me about it, as I've been reporting, basically.
我听说过。是的，在我做报道时，确实有人跟我谈论过它。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, so this movie, 2,000 Mules, it looks like a documentary, but it's really a propaganda film. It's about a stolen election theory. It's not true.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，这部电影《2000只骡子》，它看起来像纪录片，但实际上是一部宣传片。它是关于选举舞弊的阴谋论。这不是真的。
But for a while, on the right, this movie seemed like it was everywhere. Everyone seemed to be talking about it. Trump actually did a screening of it at Mar-a-Lago. It was in something like 400 movie theaters. I mean, lots and lots of people believed it. It's made by Dinesh D'Souza. He's a right-wing political commentator.
但在一段时间内，在右翼阵营里，这部电影似乎无处不在。每个人似乎都在谈论它。特朗普实际上还在海湖庄园举行了放映会。它在大约400家电影院上映。我是说，有很多人相信它。它是由迪内希·德索萨制作的。他是一位右翼政治评论员。
All right, and what's the gist?
好吧，要点是什么？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: The gist is that it's about this theory that a bunch of Democratic groups were paying people, who they call mules, to illegally collect ballots and stuff them into ballot boxes in key swing states.
扎克·圣路易斯：要点是，它基于这样一种理论，即一群民主党团体在付钱给一些人——他们称之为“骡子”——让他们非法收集选票，并将它们塞入关键摇摆州的投票箱。
Philadelphia alone, we've identified more than 1,100 mules.
仅在费城，我们就确认了超过1100名“骡子”。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So there were these talking head interviews, and they're intercut with this grainy surveillance footage that shows this person putting ballots into a box. And they're like, see? There's all the evidence you need.
扎克·圣路易斯：所以电影里有一些访谈片段，中间穿插着模糊的监控录像，显示某人把选票放入箱子。他们说：“看，这就是你所需要的所有证据。”
But that's not real surveillance footage or--
但那不是真实的监控录像，或者——
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: It is real surveillance footage, but it's showing people just dropping off ballots legally.
扎克·圣路易斯：那是真实的监控录像，但它展示的是人们合法地投递选票。
And there's scary music under it?
而且背景里有恐怖的音乐？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: There's scary music, scary voiceover.
扎克·圣路易斯：有恐怖的音乐，还有恐怖的旁白。
We are not a democracy. We are a criminal cartel masquerading as a democracy.
我们不是一个民主国家。我们是一个伪装成民主国家的犯罪集团。
[OMINOUS MUSIC]
[阴郁的音乐]
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: And when Dick watched it, like a lot of people, he thought it seemed really plausible.
扎克·圣路易斯：当迪克看这部电影时，像许多人一样，他认为这看起来非常可信。
It just added to the other stories that I was hearing, things that were happening in Arizona and Georgia. I'm thinking, yeah, there's stuff going on here that shouldn't be going on.
这只会增加我听到的其他故事，比如亚利桑那州和佐治亚州正在发生的事情。我想，是的，这里确实正在发生不该发生的事。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So Dick is watching this movie. He's reading his sources. And there are so many sources that cite so many stories about election fraud, which is part of what made it so believable.
扎克·圣路易斯：所以迪克在看这部电影，在读他的来源。有太多的来源引用了太多关于选举舞弊的故事，这就是它为何如此令人信服的部分原因。
And also, he's watching the president, President Trump, say over and over again that the election was fraudulent. It had been stolen from him.
而且，他还在反复看着总统——特朗普总统说选举是被操纵的。它被从他手中窃取了。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yes, exactly. And then Emily's consuming all of her own sources, and they say the exact opposite. And it all added to this feeling that it wasn't safe for them to talk about politics.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，完全正确。然后艾米丽也在阅读她自己的所有来源，而那些来源说的是截然相反的情况。这一切加剧了一种感觉，那就是他们谈论政治并不安全。
(INTERVIEWER) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Did that feel different from other arguments or disagreements you'd had about non-political things over your marriage?
扎克·圣路易斯：那次争论和你婚姻中关于非政治问题的争论感觉不同吗？
It did, because there was no give and take. We can argue about what we're going to spend our money on. And we can argue about our kids. We can argue about the neighborhood. But we usually come to some sort of resolution. This whole thing about Trump, there is no resolution.
确实不同，因为没有妥协。我们可以争论我们应该把钱花在什么地方。我们可以争论我们的孩子。我们可以争论社区问题。但我们通常会达成某种解决方案。关于特朗普的这一切，根本没有解决方案。
(INTERVIEWER) ZACH ST. LOUIS: How did that feel?
扎克·圣路易斯：那感觉如何？
Frustrating. [LAUGHS] Because I know my husband. I know what a smart, sensitive, thoughtful person he is. He's very generous. I know all that about him. And to have him suddenly be aligned to this person who I found absolutely despicable was very troubling.
[笑着说] 令人沮丧。因为我了解我的丈夫。我知道他是个聪明、敏感、有思想的人。他非常慷慨。关于他的一切我都知道。让他突然与这个我极其厌恶的人保持一致，是非常令人不安的。
She wouldn't talk to me. She basically just-- I don't want to talk about it. I would try. But it wasn't going to happen. And if it did, we'd end up yelling at each other. I got so angry with her one day that I finally-- I just had to walk out of the house and walk down the street to cool off.
她不跟我说话。她基本上就说——我不想谈这个。我会尝试。但这行不通。即便谈了，我们最终也会大吵大闹。有一天我被她气得不行，我终于——我不得不走出家门，沿着街道走走来冷静一下。
And then I started thinking, wow, I'm letting politics get involved in our marriage? Because I was really angry at the time. And I just couldn't stand that. I never thought that politics was important enough to jeopardize what she and I had together.
然后我开始想，哇，我竟然让政治介入了我们的婚姻？因为当时我真的很生气。我无法忍受这一点。我从没想过政治重要到足以危及我和她共同拥有的这一切。
(INTERVIEWER) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Did you feel like that it could do that, that politics could jeopardize it?
扎克·圣路易斯：你当时是否觉得它会那样做，政治会危及这一切？
Yes. I really did. I think, what did I get myself into here? Maybe I did something I shouldn't have done.
是的。我真的这么认为。我在想，我到底让自己陷入了什么境地？也许我做了一件我不该做的事。
(INTERVIEWER) ZACH ST. LOUIS: What's the mistake you're talking about?
扎克·圣路易斯：你所说的错误是什么？
Having someone that was so far left that I couldn't live with.
找了一个极端左派，让我无法与之生活的人。
Oof.
哎。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, this was a pretty low point in their marriage. And they told me that they really wanted to find a way out of it.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，这是他们婚姻中相当低谷的时期。他们告诉我，他们真的想找到出路。
We were both looking for some sort of-- I don't want to say neutral, but impartial news source.
我们都在寻找某种——我不想说中立，但至少是不偏不倚的新闻来源。
I was hungry for something that I could count on to peel the layers away and really show what's in the heart of it.
我渴望能有一些我可以依靠的东西，去剥开表象，真正看到问题的核心所在。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: They started reading different online news sources that branded themselves as being unbiased, slant-free, that kind of thing.
扎克·圣路易斯：他们开始阅读不同的在线新闻来源，这些来源自诩为不偏不倚、没有偏见，诸如此类的东西。
Interesting.
有意思。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: And then they finally landed on something. It was a newsletter. Dick seemed to like it OK. So did Emily.
扎克·圣路易斯：最后他们终于找到了一个。那是一份通讯。迪克似乎觉得还不错。艾米丽也一样。
We both agreed, oh, yes, let's read Tangle.
我们俩都同意，“哦，是的，让我们读《Tangle》吧。”
Tangle?
《Tangle》？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yes, that's the newsletter.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，那是那份通讯。
All right, so tell me about it.
好吧，跟我说说它。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: It's this daily newsletter. It comes to your email. It's, like, a Substack-type thing. It's run by a guy named Isaac Saul. He started it. He writes it. They have about 135,000 subscribers. It comes to your inbox every weekday. And each issue is all about one topic from the news.
扎克·圣路易斯：这是一份每日通讯。它发送到你的邮箱。它类似于Substack那种东西。它由一个叫艾萨克·索尔的人经营。他创办了它，他撰写它。他们大约有13.5万订阅者。它每个工作日发送到你的收件箱。每一期都围绕新闻中的一个主题。
What they try to do is summarize two or three of the best articles and arguments from right-leaning sources about that topic, and then they do the same thing with left-leaning sources. And the whole premise of the newsletter is that there are people out there like Dick and Emily that are reading completely separate sources, and why not put all of those in one place?
他们试图做的是总结两到三篇来自右翼来源的关于该主题的最佳文章和论点，然后对左翼来源做同样的事情。这份通讯的整个前提是，外面有很多像迪克和艾米丽这样阅读完全不同来源的人，为什么不把所有这些都放在同一个地方呢？
So that's what the newsletter is? It's just like, here's this topic-- here are a few stories from the left, here are a few stories from the right?
所以这就是那份通讯？它只是说——这是这个主题——这里有一些来自左翼的故事，这里有一些来自右翼的故事？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, so you can actually read what those arguments are.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，所以你可以真正读到那些论点是什么。
I think probably the first thing that astounded me was the transparency, that when they make a mistake, they correct it as soon as they realize it, and they put it right up front.
我想我最震惊的第一件事可能是透明度，当他们犯错时，他们一意识到就会纠正，并且直接放在最显眼的位置。
How is that different than corrections in a newspaper?
这和报纸上的更正有什么不同？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: A little bit, it's the way that they do it. So corrections in a newspaper, traditionally, they are at the end of the article. There will be a little footnote. Actually, we got this wrong. It's been changed above. We regret the error, in little print italics at the bottom.
扎克·圣路易斯：有点不同，关键在于他们做的方式。在报纸中，传统上更正是在文章的末尾。会有一个小小的脚注。实际上，我们这里错了。上面已经修改了。我们对这个错误表示遗憾，用底部的斜体小字。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Tangle's approach to corrections, it's a bit different.
扎克·圣路易斯：《Tangle》的更正方法略有不同。
Can you show me?
你能给我看看吗？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yes. This is from August 21. And at the very, very top, the very first thing that you see is "correction," period, in big letters.
扎克·圣路易斯：好的。这是8月21日的。在最最顶端，你看到的第一件事就是“更正”，句号，用大写字母标注。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: "In our coverage of the Medicare drug pricing negotiations yesterday, we said that four of the Medicare Part D drugs for which the government had negotiated lower prices were overprescribed in the United States. That was false. We misread the abstract of a study and rushed our review process when we included it. A sincere thank you to the 10 or so readers who caught the error."
扎克·圣路易斯：“在我们昨天关于医疗保险药品定价谈判的报道中，我们说政府谈判降低价格的四种医疗保险D部分药物在美国被过度开处方。这是错误的。我们误读了一项研究的摘要，并在纳入它时匆忙完成了审查过程。向那10位左右发现这一错误的读者表示衷心的感谢。”
And then, in italics right below that-- "This is our 114th correction in Tangle's 263-week history and our first correction since August 13. We track corrections and place them at the top of the newsletter in an effort to maximize transparency with readers."
然后，在下方的斜体字中写着——“这是《Tangle》263周历史中的第114次更正，也是自8月13日以来的第一次更正。我们追踪更正并将其放在通讯的最上方，以努力实现与读者的最大透明度。”
So this is different than a newspaper. I see.
所以这和报纸确实不同。我明白了。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的。
What else did Dick and Emily notice about Tangle?
迪克和艾米丽还注意到了关于《Tangle》的什么？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, so they noticed that it wasn't so sensational. It was more measured or even-handed in their language. So for instance, Tangle noticed that readers on the right would sometimes unsubscribe from the newsletter after reading a phrase like "undocumented immigrant." But they also didn't think it was right to call someone "illegal" or an "illegal alien." So they did this big internal review, and they settled on the term "unauthorized migrant."
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，他们注意到它并不那么耸人听闻。在措辞上它更审慎，甚至更公正。例如，《Tangle》注意到，右翼读者在阅读“无证移民”这样的词组后，有时会取消订阅。但他们也不认为称某人为“非法移民”或“非法外侨”是正确的。所以他们进行了大规模的内部审查，最终确定了“未经授权的移民”这个术语。
We really liked that approach, trying to filter out all the trigger words or the words that were very highly volatile emotionally, which helps both of us then consider the issue with less emotion about it. I'm not going to say with no emotion. [CHUCKLES] We would still argue, but with less emotion about it. And then we loved Isaac's take.
我们真的很喜欢这种方法，试图过滤掉所有的触发词或那些情绪极不稳定的词，这有助于我们双方随后以较少的情绪来考虑问题。我不会说没有情绪。[轻笑] 我们依然会争论，但会带着较少的情绪。而且我们很喜欢艾萨克的观点。
What's Isaac's take?
艾萨克的观点是什么？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So Isaac's take-- Isaac refers to Isaac Saul. He's the founder and writer of the newsletter.
扎克·圣路易斯：艾萨克的观点——艾萨克指的是艾萨克·索尔。他是这份通讯的创始人和作者。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: And at the end of every issue, he spends a long time writing his opinion. And these can be long. And he says exactly how he feels about the issue after having researched it and just describes his own feeling about it.
扎克·圣路易斯：在每一期的结尾，他会花很长时间写他的意见。这些文章可以很长。在研究过问题之后，他会明确指出自己对这个问题的感受，并描述他个人的看法。
Wait, do you have an example of this?
等等，你有这方面的例子吗？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah. Here, I'll send one to you. We can look at it.
扎克·圣路易斯：有的。来，我发给你。我们可以看一下。
All right. This was earlier this month. "Hurricane Helene and the Disaster Relief Efforts."
好的。这是本月早些时候的。“海伦飓风与灾难救援工作。”
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yes. The first part is just the topic. Then they summarize what the right is saying. They summarize what the left is saying. But then at the end, you see "My Take." And so I'm obviously not going to read this whole thing. It is--
扎克·圣路易斯：是的。第一部分只是主题。然后他们总结了右翼在说什么，总结了左翼在说什么。但在结尾，你看到了“我的观点”。显然，我不打算读完整篇东西。它大概——
Yeah, this is long. Wow.
是的，这很长。哇。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: --2,200 words. I looked.
扎克·圣路易斯：——2200字。我数过。
It's, like, a whole essay. But what's his take on Hurricane Helene?
这就像一篇完整的论文。但他对海伦飓风的观点是什么？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, so before we get to his take, I think you need to understand what he's responding to here. There have been a lot of attacks on the Biden administration from the right saying that they're doing nothing to help people who've been affected by this hurricane.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，在谈到他的观点之前，我认为你需要了解他在这里回应的是什么。右翼对拜登政府有很多攻击，称他们没有采取任何行动来帮助受这次飓风影响的人。
Like, actually nothing?
比如，真的什么都没做？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Well, that they failed to rise to the occasion, basically. So Isaac, he really puts a stake in the ground and says, there's a big problem with this narrative. It's all nonsense. It's all a lie. And then he writes, "I hate writing pieces like this. It's not my job to defend the federal government from lies. And it's hard to write a piece like this without reading it like I'm openly shilling for Harris or Biden. I am not. I'm not here to do their PR or protect their reputations.
扎克·圣路易斯：嗯，就是说他们基本上未能胜任。所以艾萨克，他确实表明了立场，说这种叙述有一个大问题。这全是无稽之谈。全是谎言。然后他写道：“我讨厌写这样的文章。为政府辩护、抵御谎言不是我的工作。如果不读这篇文章，就好像我公开在为哈里斯或拜登做说客，这很难写。我不是。我来这里不是为了做他们的公关或保护他们的名声。”
However, I do care about our information ecosystem. I care about reliable, accurate information being shared widely. I also care about the North Carolinians in danger right now, not just because they're Americans and it's a state I love, but also because my mom, my aunt, my brother and his family, my sister-in-law, and my niece, they all live in North Carolina. So the horrors we're all witnessing on the news hit close to home.
“然而，我确实关心我们的信息生态系统。我关心可靠、准确的信息被广泛分享。我也关心此刻身处险境的北卡罗来纳州人，不仅仅因为他们是美国人，这是我所爱的一个州，还因为我的母亲、姨妈、兄弟和他的家人、弟媳和侄女，他们都住在北卡罗来纳州。所以我们在新闻中目睹的恐怖，离我们很近。”
Here's the truth, though. Biden and Harris have actually pulled every lever federal executives can in a situation like this. None of the critics that I posted above can say exactly what they want them to do that they aren't already doing. And if you're planning on writing in to tell me that I am shilling for Harris or being a left-wing hack by calling out lies online, you'd better be prepared to tell me exactly what I've gotten wrong here." And then he goes on for several more paragraphs.
“不过，事实是这样的。拜登和哈里斯实际上已经拉动了联邦行政部门在这种情况下所能拉动的每一个杠杆。我在上面提到的所有批评者，都无法明确指出他们希望他们做些什么而他们尚未做的。如果你打算写信告诉我我是哈里斯的说客，或者是一个左翼黑客，因为我在网上揭露谎言，那你最好准备好告诉我我到底哪里弄错了。”然后他又写了好几个段落。
Oh, wow. Interesting. I can feel his resentment at having to defend the Democratic administration.
哦，哇。有意思。我能感觉到他不得不为民主党政府辩护时的那种愤恨。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, he's like, I don't want to do this just to defend them. But in this case, they're doing everything they can. And that's what the facts show. And so I'm going to say that.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，他就像是，“我不只是为了捍卫他们而这样做。”但在这种情况下，他们已经尽了全力。事实证明了这一点。所以我要说出来。
Right.
没错。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: And this part of the newsletter was something that Dick and Emily really came to appreciate.
扎克·圣路易斯：通讯的这一部分是迪克和艾米丽真正开始欣赏的东西。
He was very clear about what his biases were. That made him extremely trustworthy. More often than not, when we get to the end and we read "My Take," we look at each other and say, yeah, that's how I feel.
他对自己偏见的来源非常坦诚。这让他极其值得信赖。多数时候，当我们读到最后并阅读“我的观点”时，我们会看着对方说：“是的，我的感觉也是这样。”
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: They started realizing that they actually agreed with each other on a lot of things, and they were able to talk about it. And eventually, something pretty remarkable happened. So remember how Dick was totally convinced the election had been stolen? He watched 2,000 Mules. He read all of those conspiracies about it.
扎克·圣路易斯：他们开始意识到，实际上他们在很多事情上意见是一致的，而且他们能够讨论这些问题。最终，发生了相当了不起的事情。还记得迪克是如何完全确信选举是被窃取的吗？他看了《2000只骡子》。他阅读了所有关于此的阴谋论。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So as Dick and Emily were starting to have this shared understanding of the news again, Tangle did the thing for Dick that no other source seemed to be able to do, that Emily wasn't able to do, and that was prove to him that the 2020 election had not been stolen.
扎克·圣路易斯：因此，当迪克和艾米丽再次开始对新闻达成共识时，《Tangle》为迪克做到了其他任何来源似乎都无法做到的事情，艾米丽也无法做到的事情，那就是向他证明2020年大选并没有被窃取。
The only thing that changed my mind completely was the fact that I started reading Tangle. And it's only because I trust Isaac and his team so much.
唯一彻底改变我想法的事情，就是我开始阅读《Tangle》。这仅仅是因为我非常信任艾萨克和他的团队。
It's incredibly fulfilling, to be honest.
说实话，这非常有成就感。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: This is Isaac Saul. He's the guy who writes Tangle.
扎克·圣路易斯：这就是艾萨克·索尔。他是撰写《Tangle》的那个人。
Yes.
是的。
Just, it's actually so rewarding, because the election fraud stuff in particular was one of the most difficult times of my life as a reporter. The month after that election was dark, stressful, really, really hard work. And hearing that somebody had that reaction, that their mind was actually changed, even one person, it's like, yeah, it makes me want to cry. [LAUGHS]
真的，这真的很值得，因为选举舞弊问题特别是我作为记者一生中最困难的时期之一。大选后的那个月是黑暗、充满压力、非常非常辛苦的工作。听到有人有那种反应，他们的想法真的被改变了，哪怕是一个人，感觉就是，是的，这让我想要哭。[轻笑]
So am I getting this right? It seems like Isaac and this newsletter, Tangle, they seem to have done something that I feel like so many journalists, myself included, have been banging our heads against the wall, trying to figure out what to do, which is, how do you get people to believe the evidence that the 2020 election was not stolen from Donald Trump?
所以我理解对了吗？似乎艾萨克和这份《Tangle》通讯，似乎完成了我觉得很多记者——包括我自己——一直在撞墙试图找出解决办法的事情，那就是，你如何让人们相信2020年大选没有从唐纳德·特朗普手中被窃取的证据？
Something like a third of Americans believe that it was. It's really threatening our ability to function. How do you present those facts and get people to believe them? I mean, we did a whole episode of our show about Barton Gellman, one of the greatest investigative reporters of our time, I'd say, who quit journalism because of this problem.
大约有三分之一的美国人相信它是被窃取的。这确实威胁到了我们的运作能力。你如何呈现这些事实并让人们相信它们？我的意思是，我们甚至为巴顿·格尔曼——我认为是我们时代最伟大的调查记者之一——做过一整期节目，他因为这个问题而放弃了新闻工作。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的。
And you're saying Tangle did it.
你说《Tangle》做到了。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: In this case, Tangle did it. Yeah, for Dick, Tangle did it.
扎克·圣路易斯：在这个例子中，《Tangle》做到了。是的，对于迪克来说，《Tangle》做到了。
All right. So how did Tangle do this? How did Isaac, the guy who runs this, do this?
好吧。那么《Tangle》是怎么做到的？经营这份通讯的家伙——艾萨克是怎么做到的？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, so Isaac did a ton of work around this whole election denialism issue. It wasn't just one newsletter. Every time a new claim about how the election may have been stolen surfaced, he would spend all this time running it down, explaining in detail why it was false. He did that in the days and weeks immediately following the election. He continued doing it as new claims surfaced in the years since.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，艾萨克在整个选举否认问题上做了大量工作。不仅仅是一份通讯。每当出现关于选举如何被窃取的新说法时，他都会花所有时间去调查，并详细解释为什么它是虚假的。他在大选后的几天和几周内就是这么做的。随着后来几年新说法的出现，他继续这样做。
But a lot of news sources have done this, looked at these different claims about how the election was stolen and showed why they aren't true, and looked at the court cases where no evidence surfaced and all this stuff, right?
但许多新闻来源都做过这件事，审视了这些关于选举如何被窃取的不同说法，展示了它们为什么不是真的，并审视了没有任何证据出现的法庭案件以及所有这些东西，对吧？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: They did. But Isaac was doing a lot of research. Like, for example, in the weeks following the election, right after, he did this 400-tweet-long thread that was going in detail into each claim. He was really, really deep on this.
扎克·圣路易斯：他们做过。但艾萨克做了很多研究。例如，在大选后的几周，就在那之后，他写了这条长达400条推文的线索，深入探讨了每一个主张。他确实对此非常非常深入。
But I don't think it was only the research that helped convince Dick. There's something else that Isaac did. And it was in his tone and how he approached this whole issue, especially around the claims that seemed more persuasive. He didn't just write them off. He assessed them seriously. He presented them seriously. And that didn't make Dick feel stupid. Here's Isaac.
但我认为不只是研究帮助说服了迪克。艾萨克还做了其他事情。这体现在他的语气以及他处理整个问题的方式上，尤其是在围绕那些看起来更具说服力的主张时。他没有直接忽略它们。他认真地评估了它们。他认真地呈现了它们。这没有让迪克觉得愚蠢。这是艾萨克。
Some of the stuff was really convincing. And proving that they were wrong was not as simple as saying, oh, this is just conspiracy nonsense. Like, the ballot stuffing thing, that was a plausible way to steal an election.
有些东西确实很有说服力。证明它们是错误的并不像说“哦，这只是阴谋诡计”那么简单。比如，塞选票的事情，那是一个窃取选举的可信方式。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: In 2022, he actually dedicated an entire newsletter, a deep dive, into 2,000 Mules, that movie we were talking about.
扎克·圣路易斯：2022年，他实际上用整整一期通讯，做了一次关于《2000只骡子》的深入报道，就是我们刚才谈到的那部电影。
So when that movie came out and everybody just laughs at Dinesh D'Souza, I was kind of like, I'm going to watch it and take some of these allegations seriously and see what's up. It turned out they were all bullshit, but you only know that if you actually do some of the work.
所以当那部电影出来，大家都只是嘲笑迪内希·德索萨时，我就想，“我要去看它，认真对待这些指控中的一些，看看是怎么回事。”结果它们全是扯淡，但只有你真的做了点工作才知道。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Can I actually just read you what he wrote at the top of that newsletter?
扎克·圣路易斯：我能读给你听听他在那期通讯开头写了什么吗？
Yeah, please.
好的，请读。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So the title of the newsletter is "An Honest Look at 2,000 Mules, the New Stolen Election Theory." And this is how he opens it. "I consider myself to be both a skeptic and an open-minded person. I am deeply cynical about our government, believe intelligence agencies are covering up the truth about UFOs, and don't feel any particular loyalty to any major political parties. I generally distrust authority, government agencies, and politicians.
扎克·圣路易斯：那期通讯的标题是“诚实审视《2000只骡子》，新的被窃选举理论。”他是这样开头的：“我自认为既是一个怀疑论者，又是一个思想开放的人。我对我们的政府深感愤世嫉俗，相信情报机构在掩盖关于不明飞行物的真相，并且对任何主要政党都没有什么特别的忠诚。我通常不信任权威、政府机构和政客。”
But I do believe it's wise to consult expert opinions and advice. I love a good conspiracy, a good cover-up, and a great story. A stolen presidential election would be an all-timer in every regard, a story so gigantic, a conspiracy of corruption and power so unthinkable that the idea alone is tantalizing enough. I almost want to believe it." And then he goes on to dissect every point made in the film and show why it's inaccurate. But that's how he starts.
“但我相信咨询专家的意见和建议是明智的。我喜欢好的阴谋、好的掩盖和好的故事。一场被窃取的总统大选在任何方面都会成为历史级别的事件，一个如此巨大的故事，一个如此难以想象的腐败和权力的阴谋，单是这个想法本身就足够诱人了。我甚至想相信它。”然后他继续剖析电影中提出的每一点，并展示为什么它是不准确的。但他就是这样开始的。
Interesting. OK, so that's the presentation difference you're talking about?
有意思。好的，这就是你所说的呈现方式的不同？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah. And I'll just say that that framing, it's really different from how other outlets covered this film. Like, for example, there's a New York Times headline about the movie. It was, quote, "A Big Lie in a New Package." There was a Washington Post headline that was, quote, "2,000 Mules Offers the Least Convincing Election Fraud Theory Yet."
扎克·圣路易斯：是的。我只想说，这种框架确实不同于其他媒体报道这部电影的方式。例如，《纽约时报》关于这部电影的标题是，引用，“新包装中的弥天大谎。”《华盛顿邮报》的标题是，引用，“《2000只骡子》提供了迄今为止最不具说服力的选举舞弊理论。”
And look, I mean, that's all true. It is a lie. But Isaac realized he's probably not going to convince someone who already believes the lie by leading with that. So instead, he levels with people, explains where he's coming from and all the research he did, and then explains what he found about the claims. And so this was what Dick was reading.
看，我是说，这都是真的。那是一个谎言。但艾萨克意识到，他大概无法通过那样的方式来说服已经相信谎言的人。所以相反，他与人们处于同一水平，解释了他的来源以及他所做的所有研究，然后解释了他发现关于这些指控的内容。所以这就是迪克一直在读的东西。
After reading his article, what I realized was-- and he even admitted there were some things that were happening that shouldn't have been happening in some of the polls. But it wouldn't have changed the dynamics of who won and who lost at all. That was actually the first time I really realized it for sure. And that really opened my eyes to how corrupt that was. That really sold me on the fact that the election wasn't stolen.
读了他的文章后，我意识到的是——他甚至承认在一些投票站发生了一些不该发生的事情。但这根本不会改变谁输谁赢的动态。那是第一次我真正确信这一点。这真的让我大开眼界，看到了那是多么腐败。那真的让我相信选举没有被窃取。
What I was thinking in my head was, like, I want to bring all these people in my life under one roof, and I want them to be able to read a news source that the Trump MAGA bro will trust and the left-wing Bernie bro will trust.
我脑子里想的是，我想把生活中所有这些人带到同一个屋檐下，我想让他们能够阅读一个特朗普MAGA兄弟会信任，左翼桑德斯兄弟也会信任的新闻来源。
What was the origin story for Tangle for Isaac? He was a reporter before this?
《Tangle》对艾萨克来说起源故事是什么？他在这之前是记者吗？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, he was a reporter. He worked for Huffington Post, a couple of other places. And he told me that he's always been the type of person that's brought together people from different backgrounds in his personal life. Maybe they don't agree, and he's often mediating between those people. But really, the inspiration for Tangle came out of his own news consumption.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，他是一名记者。他曾在《赫芬顿邮报》工作过，也在其他几个地方工作过。他告诉我，他一直是一个在个人生活中将不同背景的人聚在一起的人。也许他们意见不合，他经常在这些人之间进行调解。但《Tangle》的灵感实际上来自于他自己的新闻消费。
The idea for Tangle basically came from the Trump era of, Trump proposes a border wall, and I'm like, he's proposing a 2,000-mile border wall. This sounds totally insane. I can't imagine the best argument for this. But I really want to understand, is this something that would actually work?
《Tangle》的构思基本上源于特朗普时代，“特朗普提议修建边境墙，而我就想，他提议修建一条2000英里的边境墙。这听起来完全疯狂。我无法想象这最好的论点是什么。但我真的很想理解，这东西真的会奏效吗？”
And in order to grasp what was actually happening, my day would be like, I'm going to go read The New York Times editorial board. I'm going to read their immigration reporting about it. Then I'm going to go to Fox News and scroll through their opinion page and search for Trump's border wall.
为了弄清到底发生了什么，我的一天会是这样的：“我要去读《纽约时报》的编辑委员会。我要读他们关于此的移民报道。然后我要去福克斯新闻，滚动浏览他们的意见页面，搜索特朗普的边境墙。”
And then maybe I'll listen to a Ben Shapiro podcast, and then I'll go listen to Pod Save America. And then I'll watch The Daily Show do a bit about it, or watch John Oliver. And then I'll spend an hour on some Tucker Carlson special about it.
然后也许我会听本·夏皮罗的播客，然后我会去听《Pod Save America》。然后我会看《每日秀》做一个相关的段子，或者看约翰·奥利弗。然后我会花一个小时看塔克·卡尔森关于此的特别节目。
And then I'll do 10 hours of all this consuming of the news. And I'll sit down, and I'll be like, OK, I think I now have a really good understanding of everybody's perspective, positive and negative, about this policy proposal. Why can't I just find that one place? That should exist somewhere.
然后我会花10个小时做这一切消费新闻。我会坐下来，我会说：“好吧，我想我现在对每个人——赞成的和反对的——关于这个政策建议的视角有了很好的理解。为什么我就不能找到那一个地方呢？那应该存在于某个地方。”
Do you know who's reading the newsletter?
你知道是谁在读这份通讯吗？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: I kind of do, based on a reader survey of Tangle subscribers. So a little bit over half of the subscribers are men, around 57%. It skews very white, just below 90% of readers. It's US-based, but Isaac says it does reach something like 55 other countries. And about a third of the readers say that they're on the left, a third on the right, and the last third are either center or independent.
扎克·圣路易斯：我根据一份《Tangle》订阅者的读者调查大概知道。订阅者中略多于一半是男性，约为57%。它非常白人化，不到90%的读者。它以美国为基地，但艾萨克说它确实到达了其他55个国家左右。大约三分之一的读者说他们是在左翼，三分之一在右翼，最后三分之一要么是中间派，要么是独立派。
Wow, so it's pretty evenly politically split.
哇，所以在政治上分得很均匀。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, pretty even split politically. And I did talk to some other readers of the newsletter who said that it had an impact on them, similar to Dick and Emily.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，在政治上相当均匀。我确实与该通讯的其他一些读者交谈过，他们说它对他们产生了影响，类似于迪克和艾米丽的情况。
Like who?
比如谁？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: I met this one guy at a political event in New York, and he told me it's basically the only news that he reads. I talked to a new reader of Tangle-- a journalist, actually-- and he said that there were some arguments from the right that he'd just written off. But reading Tangle actually helped him see that they had a point. And I even spoke to another guy who, like Dick, had his mind changed about the 2020 election.
扎克·圣路易斯：我在纽约的一次政治活动上遇到了一个人，他告诉我这基本上是他阅读的唯一新闻。我与《Tangle》的一位新读者交谈过——实际上也是一名记者——他说有一些来自右翼的论点他原本只是忽略了。但阅读《Tangle》实际上帮助他看到他们确实有道理。我甚至和另一个人谈过，像迪克一样，他的想法关于2020年大选被改变了。
I assumed that Donald Trump was telling me the truth, that they had firm evidence that it was definitely manipulation of the ballots.
我原以为唐纳德·特朗普告诉我的是真相，他们确实有确凿的证据表明这绝对是选票操纵。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: This is a guy named Rick.
扎克·圣路易斯：这是一个叫里克的人。
Wait, Rick and Dick?
等等，里克和迪克？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Rick and Dick.
扎克·圣路易斯：里克和迪克。
OK.
好的。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Both Richard, if you want to be technical about it.
扎克·圣路易斯：如果你想从技术上讲，他们都叫理查德。
Got it. Go on.
明白了。继续。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: It's a really similar story to Dick and Emily's. Rick was a big Trump supporter, voted for him twice. Rick's son is on the left politically. They were arguing about the news a lot. And the son started forwarding Rick the newsletter, including issues that were about the stolen election claims.
扎克·圣路易斯：这和迪克与艾米丽的故事非常相似。里克曾是特朗普的大支持者，投过他两次票。里克的儿子在政治上是左派。他们经常争论新闻。儿子开始把这份通讯转给里克，包括那些关于被窃选举指控的内容。
They weren't just laughing it off. I have a trust in their news gathering and presentation abilities head and shoulders above any other news gathering source. I have a trust level there that's unequaled.
他们不只是在嘲笑它。我对他们的新闻搜集和呈现能力有着比任何其他新闻搜集来源都高得多的信任。那种信任水平是无与伦比的。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: And again, like Dick and Emily, Rick and his son have mended their relationship. They can talk to each other about the news again. And now, he doesn't think the election was stolen. And that feeling of being lied to, it's actually convinced him not to vote for Trump this year.
扎克·圣路易斯：同样，像迪克和艾米丽一样，里克和他的儿子修复了他们的关系。他们又可以互相讨论新闻了。现在，他不认为选举被窃取了。那种被欺骗的感觉，实际上说服了他今年不要投票给特朗普。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. The only reason I wouldn't vote for him is because he made me look foolish in front of my son.
是的。我唯一不投票给他的原因是，他让我在我儿子面前看起来很愚蠢。
Zach, you mentioned the importance of striking the right tone when we're presenting evidence, especially evidence that's contrary to what someone believes. And that does seem important. But also just hearing the story of Rick and his son alongside the story of Dick and Emily, his wife, I do just wonder, does a person have to be motivated to get along with someone they love to repair a relationship, essentially, in order to change their mind?
扎克，你提到了在呈现证据时采取正确语气的重要性，尤其是与某人所信相反的证据。这看起来确实很重要。但同时，听到里克和他儿子的故事，以及迪克和他的妻子艾米丽的故事，我确实好奇，一个人是否必须有动机与他们所爱的人和睦相处——本质上是为了修复关系——才能改变他们的想法？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, it's a good question. Wanting to see something from someone else's perspective, the perspective of someone you love, it seems like that doesn't hurt.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，这是个好问题。想要从别人的角度看问题，也就是你爱的人的视角，这看起来没有坏处。
It's interesting, thinking about it. It's not exactly that Tangle moved both of them towards the center, and they met in the middle. But it moved Dick more towards Emily, basically.
有意思，思考一下。这并不完全是《Tangle》推动他们两人都走向中间，并在中间会合。而是它基本上推动迪克更多地走向了艾米丽。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, I mean, obviously, it would make for a better story if they each moved toward the center. I think that's sort of--
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，我是说，显然如果他们各自都走向中间，那会构成一个更好的故事。我想那有点——
Met in the middle.
在中间会合。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: --what we want from a story like this. Exactly, met in the middle. But it's really more like Dick believed something that wasn't true. And then he was the one that moved toward facts.
扎克·圣路易斯：——我们从这样的故事中想要的东西。完全正确，在中间会合。但更像是迪克相信了一些不真实的事情。然后他成了那个走向事实的人。
How does Emily say it changed her? Does she say it changed her?
艾米丽怎么说它改变了她？她说它改变了她吗？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: So she told me that she didn't have as dramatic a change as Dick. It wasn't like she believed something that wasn't true and had her mind changed. But she says she does read the news differently now. For instance, she told me that hearing some of Kamala Harris's policy proposals and how, before, she would have taken some of them at face value as good ideas. Now, she says she's thinking more critically about them.
扎克·圣路易斯：所以她告诉我，她不像迪克那样有戏剧性的改变。不像她相信了某些不真实的东西并改变了主意。但她说她现在阅读新闻的方式不同了。例如，她告诉我，听到卡玛拉·哈里斯的一些政策建议，以前她会直接接受其中一些作为好主意。现在，她说她正在更批判性地思考它们。
Hmm. How are they doing these days?
嗯。他们最近怎么样？
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Yeah, the last time I spoke to them, they really did seem to be in a better place. I think on the surface, it seemed like their problem was that they'd been talking across this political divide. But their real problem was that they weren't agreeing on facts. They weren't agreeing on what was true. That's what made it so bitter.
扎克·圣路易斯：是的，上次我和他们交谈时，他们看起来确实处于更好的状态。我认为表面上，看起来他们的问题是他们在这种政治鸿沟中交流。但他们真正的问题是他们在事实上没有达成共识。他们对什么是真的没有共识。那才是让它如此痛苦的原因。
It's a huge relief. Dick and I can now agree on more or disagree based on the same information, at least.
这是一种巨大的解脱。迪克和我现在至少可以在更多事情上达成一致，或者基于相同的信息存在分歧。
I don't feel like I'm walking on eggshells if I want to mention something to her. I mean, she's her own person. I'm not going to tell her who to vote for. And she wouldn't listen to me anyway.
如果我想向她提什么，我不觉得我在如履薄冰。我是说，她是她自己的人。我不会告诉她该投票给谁。反正她也不会听我的。
Now, we're on the same handbook, more or less, although he might be reading a different page than me at the time. But it's generally the same handbook.
现在，我们基本上在同一本手册上，尽管他读的页码可能跟我此时读的不同。但它基本上是同一本手册。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: But I mean, agreeing on the same set of facts, being in the same book, that's only going to get you so far.
扎克·圣路易斯：但我意思是，就同一套事实达成一致，在同一本书里，这只能把你带到这里。
Who's Dick voting for?
迪克投票给谁？
As far as I'm concerned, I don't like Trump as a person. The way he handles himself, the things he says-- it bothers me a lot. But the one thing that I did like about him was his policies. And so I'm definitely leaning towards Trump still.
就我而言，我不喜欢特朗普这个人。他处理自己的方式，他所说的话——这让我非常困扰。但我喜欢他的一点是他的政策。所以我在绝对还是倾向于特朗普。
OK, that's Dick's--
好的，那是迪克的——
That's my take.
那是我的观点。
That's the first time that he's verbalized to me that he's thinking about voting for Trump. My heart just stopped.
这是他第一次向我表达他正在考虑投票给特朗普。我的心都要停跳了。
(HOST) ZACH ST. LOUIS: Emily and Dick Newton in Orange County, California.
扎克·圣路易斯：加利福尼亚州奥兰治县的艾米丽和迪克·牛顿。
So that's Brian Reed and Zach St. Louis of the podcast Question Everything, which is produced by KCRW and Placement Theory. The story was edited by Jonathan Goldstein and Robyn Semien. Coming up, other couples muddling their way through this election using slightly more extreme tactics. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
那就是播客《质疑一切》的布莱恩·里德和扎克·圣路易斯，该节目由KCRW和Placement Theory制作。故事由乔纳森·戈德斯坦和罗宾·塞米恩编辑。接下来，其他夫妻在这次选举中通过稍微极端一点的策略，理清他们的道路。一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, A Small Thing That Gives Me a Tiny Shred of Hope. OK, so it was Act One and the Tangle newsletter that inspired that name for today's episode.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《一件带给我一丝希望的小事》。好吧，就是第一幕和《Tangle》通讯启发了今天这一集的标题。
Now, in the second half of the show, the thread from that story that we're going to pick up and keep pulling is what is happening with couples during this election, which is interesting, because as you probably heard, there's a real gender gap between men and women this time out. Men prefer Trump by 8 percentage points. Women prefer Harris by 9. With that, we turn to Act Two of our show. Act Two, "'Til Death Do Us Partisan."
现在，在节目的后半部分，我们将拾起并继续深入探讨故事中的那个线索，那就是在这次选举中夫妻们正在发生什么，这很有意思，因为正如你可能听到的，这次在男人和女人之间确实存在真正的性别鸿沟。男性更倾向于特朗普8个百分点。女性更倾向于哈里斯9个百分点。带着这一点，我们转向节目的第二幕。第二幕，“直到死亡将我们党派化”。
OK, so if you remember Emily and Dick, who we heard in Act One, they talk openly between them about their political differences. One of our producers, Aviva DeKornfeld, spoke with a woman who is taking a different tactic with her husband.
好吧，所以如果你还记得我们在第一幕听到的艾米丽和迪克，他们之间公开谈论他们的政治分歧。我们的一位制作人，阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德，与一位对她的丈夫采取不同策略的女士交谈。
It's been hard to find a time to talk with June. She's on a three-week road trip with her husband, and they have almost no time apart. So we look for little cracks in her schedule to sneak in a call.
很难找到时间与琼交谈。她正和她的丈夫进行为期三周的公路旅行，他们几乎没有分开的时间。所以我们寻找她时间表中的小缝隙来偷偷打个电话。
Do you have a sense of how much time we have right now?
你知道我们现在有多少时间吗？
Probably about a half an hour. He's in the shower.
大概半小时吧。他在洗澡。
OK. Wow, half an hour. Long shower. Luxurious. [CHUCKLES]
好的。哇，半小时。长时间洗澡。真奢侈。[轻笑]
Oh, well, he has a whole routine-- teeth and everything. [LAUGHS]
哦，好吧，他有一整套流程——牙齿什么的。[大笑]
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
He's like a teenage girl in that way.
他在这方面就像个十几岁的女孩。
OK, do you mind if I record this call?
好的，你介意我录这个电话吗？
I don't mind, but I'm a little bit concerned about-- I don't want to get in trouble.
我不介意，但我有点担心——我不想惹麻烦。
The trouble June's trying to avoid is an argument with her husband. They're both conservatives. But after voting Republican for her entire life, this election, June will be secretly voting for Kamala Harris. Her husband doesn't know about her plans.
琼试图避免的麻烦是和她丈夫的争吵。他们都是保守派。但在一生投票给共和党之后，这次选举，琼将秘密投票给卡玛拉·哈里斯。她丈夫不知道她的计划。
And so that's sort of why I'm a secret voter, is because I'll vote however I want to vote. But having the conversations about it is where things get just uncomfortable.
所以这就是为什么我是一个秘密选民，因为我会投票给任何我想投的人。但谈论这件事的地方却让事情变得不舒服。
While we talk, June is pacing around the backyard of their rental house, where her husband can't hear her. It's not like she's scared of him. She just doesn't want to fight with him, which is why we're using a pseudonym. June's not her real name.
当我们谈话时，琼在她租房的后院里踱步，她的丈夫听不到她说话。并不是她怕他。她只是不想和他吵架，这就是为什么我们使用化名。琼不是她的真名。
The Harris campaign is counting on the idea that there are lots of Junes out there. They're marketing to these women specifically, sending Republicans like Liz Cheney all over the country to talk to them. And there's a whole grassroots effort of people sticking Post-It notes in public restrooms, reminding these women their vote is private.
哈里斯竞选团队寄希望于外面有许多琼这样的人。他们专门针对这些女性进行营销，派遣像利兹·切尼这样的共和党人到全国各地与她们交谈。还有一个全民草根努力，人们把便利贴贴在公共洗手间里，提醒这些女性她们的投票是私密的。
I wondered what it was like for people in this situation. Is it really possible to keep a secret like this from the person you share a house and a life with? How do you do that? What are the consequences?
我想知道处在这种情况下的人是什么感觉。真的有可能对你与之共同生活和分享生活的人保守这样的秘密吗？你是怎么做到的？后果是什么？
On our call, June made a point to say it wasn't always this way. She's been with her husband, who I'll call Rick, for 20 years now. They first met in an online group for single parents. June had three little kids from a previous, pretty rough marriage. Rick had two kids. And their courtship started over the phone.
在我们的通话中，琼特别说明情况并不总是这样的。她和她的丈夫——我叫他里克——已经在一起20年了。他们最初是在一个单身父母的在线小组里认识的。琼有一段粗暴婚姻留下的三个小孩。里克有两个孩子。他们的求爱始于电话。
Yes, I mean, like being in middle school. Like, you'd spend all day with your best friend in middle school and then immediately come home and get on the phone with her. We would just talk for hours and hours and hours. It just felt like the easiest, most natural connection.
是的，我是说，就像在初中一样。就像，你会在初中和最好的朋友待上一整天，然后立刻回家和她打电话。我们可以连续谈上几个小时几个小时。那感觉就像最简单、最自然的联系。
By the time June and Rick actually met in real life a few months later, they were basically already a couple. A year later, they got married, and Rick raised June's kids as his own-- calls them his kids. June says Rick was totally apolitical when they met, had never voted, wasn't even registered, which did not sit right with June. She's always been very politically engaged, makes a real effort to vote in every election, not just the big ones.
等到琼和里克几个月后在现实生活中真正见面时，他们基本上已经是夫妻了。一年后，他们结婚了，里克把琼的孩子当成自己的孩子抚养——称他们为他的孩子。琼说里克在他们相识时完全不关心政治，从未投过票，甚至没有登记，这让琼觉得不对劲。她一直非常积极地参与政治，努力在每一次选举中投票，不仅是大型选举。
Since June was a lifelong Republican, Rick also registered as a Republican. And in 2016, they both voted for Donald Trump together. But June immediately regretted it. She never liked Trump, but it felt wrong to her not to vote, and she assumed he wouldn't win anyway. After the election, June started to lean away from her political party. But Rick reached towards it. He started watching Fox News every day.
由于琼是一位终身共和党人，里克也登记为共和党人。2016年，他们两人一起投票给唐纳德·特朗普。但琼立即后悔了。她从不喜欢特朗普，但对她来说不投票感觉不对，她认为他反正也不会赢。选举后，琼开始远离她的政党。但里克却向它靠拢。他开始每天看福克斯新闻。
And it's just stirring something up inside of him that makes him afraid, or just angsty, or whatever. And it just comes bubbling out. He's not a big talker to anybody else. I'm the main person that he talks to. So I think if he talked to a lot of people, maybe I wouldn't be getting so much of it down the barrel.
这只会激发他内心深处的一些东西，让他害怕，或者只是焦虑，或者其他什么。然后它就冒出来了。他不是一个对别人多话的人。我是他交谈的主要对象。所以我认为如果他跟很多人谈话，也许我不会承受这么多压力。
But because I'm his main person, I think I get it all, because I think it makes him very anxious. Like, if you heard and believed every day that you're going to lose your freedom, you're going to lose your job, you're going to lose your way of life, all these terrible things are going to happen, I think it's natural that you would be anxious.
但因为我是他最主要的人，我认为我承受了所有这些，因为我认为这让他非常焦虑。就像，如果你每天听到并相信你会失去自由，你会失去工作，你会失去你的生活方式，所有这些可怕的事情都会发生，我认为你感到焦虑是很自然的。
Does he have friends?
他有朋友吗？
No. [CHUCKLING]
没有。[轻笑]
Not even one?
连一个都没有？
I mean, he has-- so one of the pastors at my church really likes him. But no, he doesn't really like people very much. [CHUCKLING]
我是说，所以我在教堂的一位牧师真的很喜欢他。但没有，他其实不太喜欢人。[轻笑]
Rick used to ask June about her opinion on politics. She would read articles, and he would ask her to summarize them for him. That was the dynamic. She researched and came to an opinion, and he trusted her opinions. But these days--
里克过去常问琼关于她对政治的看法。她会读文章，他会让她为他总结。那是当时的动态。她做研究并形成观点，而他信任她的观点。但这些天——
The longer that Donald Trump has been on the picture, the sort of more like him my husband becomes. Just, I'm not allowed to have my own opinions. And I'd better not vote this way or that way, or I'm going to go with you and vote, and just really getting very hostile about it.
唐纳德·特朗普在画面中出现的时间越长，我的丈夫变得越像他。就是，我不被允许有我自己的观点。而且我最好不要这样或那样投票，否则我将和你一起去投票，而且真的对此变得非常敌对。
And I guess Donald Trump just made it easier, or more acceptable, or more popular to act like that. And it's the only area where he's like that. But if we have a big confrontation about it, then it becomes everything, you know? It's just--
而且我猜唐纳德·特朗普只是让表现得那样更容易，或者更被接受，或者更受欢迎。而且这是他那样的唯一领域。但如果我们对此有大的冲突，那就会变得一切，你知道吗？这只是——
[DOG BARKING]
[狗叫声]
Oh, I hear a little dog in the background.
哦，我听到背景里有只小狗。
Yes, yes. We have the puppies with us, too. [LAUGHS]
是的，是的。我们带了小狗一起。[大笑]
June is having this disagreement with her husband during a moment when election coverage is nonstop. Ads are everywhere. Both campaigns are relentlessly calling and texting and emailing, all while she's stuck in a car with her husband. And this is all he wants to talk about. She said they planned this trip a year ago, when things were calm. And now, she can't believe she did this to herself. It's been very tense.
琼正在与她的丈夫进行这场分歧，当时选举报道不停。广告无处不在。两个竞选团队都在无情地打电话、发短信和发邮件，同时她还被困在与她丈夫的车里。这就是他想要谈论的一切。她说他们一年前计划了这次旅行，当时情况很平静。现在，她无法相信她对自己做了这件事。这非常紧张。
But June's got a couple strategies for dealing when politics comes up. Sometimes, she tries something called gray rocking, which is basically just being as boring as possible in conversation so Rick has nothing to seize on or react to. Other times, she tries for a classic maneuver-- the dodge.
但琼有几个策略来处理政治问题出现时的情况。有时，她尝试一种叫“灰岩”的方法，这基本上就是让交谈尽可能无聊，这样里克就没什么可抓住或反应的了。其他时候，她尝试一个经典的动作——躲避。
I dodge a lot. No, I'm pretty good at dodging, because I'm very busy. Honey, I'm very busy making dinner. I'm very busy with the cleaning, or I have to do some work, or whatever. So I'd say maybe once every 10 days to two weeks do I let my guard down.
我躲避得很多。不，我非常擅长躲避，因为我非常忙。亲爱的，我正忙着做晚饭。我正忙着打扫，或者我得做点工作，或者其他什么。所以我说大概每10天到两周我才会放下警惕。
And when her guard drops, a fight ensues. They have a big fight every 10 days to two weeks because he keeps bringing politics up. He wants to talk to her about all this stuff. And it unsettles him when they're not on the same page. He wants her to engage. And so her refusal itself becomes a kind of fuel.
当她放下警惕时，争吵就发生了。他们每10天到两周就有一次大争吵，因为他不停地提起政治。他想跟她谈论所有这些东西。当他们不在同一页面上时，这让他不安。他希望她参与。所以她本身的拒绝成了一种燃料。
It ends up being very pushy, you know. Like, why aren't you talking to me? Why don't you answer me? He'll say things, and I just take the bait, you know. He'll say, you're a liberal.
这最终变得非常具有攻击性，你知道。就像，为什么你不跟我说话？为什么不回答我？他会说些话，而我只是上了钩，你知道。他会说，你是个自由派。
And what do you say?
那你怎么说？
I say, I've been a conservative longer than you've been a conservative.
我说，我做保守派的时间比你做保守派的时间长。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What are you talking about?
你在说什么？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
I am a conservative. Donald Trump stole my party. [LAUGHS]
我是一个保守派。唐纳德·特朗普窃取了我的党。[大笑]
Do you regret getting him politically engaged, given how things have turned out?
考虑到事情的结果，你是否后悔让他参与政治？
Totally.
完全后悔。
Really?
真的吗？
Totally, yes.
完全，是的。
I talked to a bunch of people like June, women who plan to vote for Kamala, but are going to all sorts of lengths to avoid telling their family and friends about it. They're all lifelong conservatives. But then, for a lot of them, January 6 crossed a red line they didn't even know they had until it happened. And now, they can't bring themselves to vote for Trump again.
我和一群像琼这样的人谈过，她们计划投票给卡玛拉，但想方设法避免告诉家人和朋友这件事。她们都是终身的保守派。但后来，对她们中的许多人来说，1月6日跨越了一条她们甚至不知道自己有的红线。现在，她们无法说服自己再投特朗普的票。
I talked to one woman in Louisiana who told me her parents knew she wasn't going to vote for Trump. They assume she's going to write in another Republican, which she's happy to let them think. She said it's inconceivable to her parents that she could possibly vote for a Democrat.
我和路易斯安那州的一位女士谈过，她告诉我她的父母知道她不会投特朗普。他们以为她会写下另一个共和党人，她很高兴让他们那样认为。她说她父母无法想象她竟然会投票给民主党人。
Another woman in Missouri told me that once Kamala entered the race, she tried to test the waters with her family, said she was thinking that maybe she would vote for Kamala. Her family's reaction was so strong-- they said she was going to hell, that she was a communist-- that she had to backtrack. They haven't talked about it again since. I mentioned all this to June.
密苏里州的另一位女士告诉我，卡玛拉一旦进入竞选，她就试图测试家人的反应，说她正在考虑也许会投票给卡玛拉。她家人的反应如此强烈——他们说她会下地狱，说她是共产主义者——以至于她不得不撤回。从那以后他们再也没谈过这件事。我把所有这些都告诉了琼。
I've talked to a bunch of people who are in different versions of your situation, and everyone tries to avoid talking about politics with their family because they obviously want to maintain close relationships with their family. And they avoid talking about it in service of the relationship. But actually, they just can't be as close with their family as they want to be if they can't really share this part of their life with them.
我跟很多人谈过，他们处在你这种情况的不同版本中，每个人都试图避免跟家人谈论政治，因为他们显然想跟家人保持密切关系。为了关系他们避免谈论它，但实际上，如果他们不能真正与家人分享生活的这一部分，他们就无法像他们想要的那样亲近家人。
Right. I think we sort of watch movies and TV shows where one explosive thing happens that ends up destroying a relationship or whatever it is. But I think in actuality, those kinds of deteriorations happen little by little over time. And it's these small, small things that chip away at any family relationship, or any kind of relationship. And so I think I probably just make a short-term, easy decision to avoid it. And it probably does have longer-term consequences.
没错。我想我们有点像是在电影和电视节目中看到那种爆炸性的事情发生，最终导致毁灭了一段关系或什么的。但我认为实际上，这种恶化是随着时间一点一点发生的。正是这些细小细小的事情削弱了任何家庭关系，或任何一种关系。所以我认为我可能只是做了一个短期、容易的决定来避免它。这很可能有更长期的后果。
I want to be clear. June and Rick still have nice parts of their marriage. They still go on their daily walks. They have those two little dogs that they both obsess over. Rick does this whole routine with the dogs during their nightly snack time, which delights June. But with the wall-to-wall election noise, politics is increasingly crowding out those other, more peaceful parts of their lives.
我想说清楚。琼和里克仍然有婚姻的美好部分。他们依然每天散步。他们有那两只他们俩都着迷的小狗。里克在每晚零食时间跟狗有一套完整的流程，这让琼很高兴。但随着无处不在的选举噪音，政治正日益挤掉他们生活中其他更平静的部分。
I have an older sister who's married to a like-minded man, and their relationship is just so different. There's just so much more back and forth between the two of them. And there's so much less just angst about-- she can be who she wants to be, and he's just more secure in that. She can voice her opinion. And it just doesn't ever seem like she's looking over her shoulder.
我有个姐姐，她嫁给了一个志同道合的男人，他们的关系真的太不同了。他们两人之间有太多的来来回回。而且那种焦虑少得多——她可以成为她想成为的人，而他在这一点上更安全。她可以表达她的观点。而且看起来她从来不需要回头看。
But I definitely feel like I need to look over my shoulder, obviously. I'm sitting in my backyard. [LAUGHS] I just feel like I have to look over my back shoulder, not because something necessarily bad will happen to me, but it's just too exhausting to keep explaining myself, I guess. I just don't really want to keep doing that.
但我绝对觉得我需要回头看，显然。我正坐在我的后院里。[大笑] 我只是觉得我必须回头看，并不是因为一定会发生什么坏事，但这只是太累了，不断解释我自己，我想。我真的不想再这样做了。
Who does your husband think you're voting for?
你丈夫以为你投票给谁？
[LAUGHS] I think he's afraid that I'm going to vote for Kamala. I think he has a clue that I'm a never-Trumper. But I wouldn't say he knows for 100% sure.
[大笑] 我想他害怕我会投票给卡玛拉。我想他有点意识到我是个“决不特朗普”主义者。但我不会说他100%确定。
Tell me if this is way off base--
告诉我如果这离谱了——
Sure.
好的。
--because I don't mean to overstep-- but it sounds kind of lonely being in a--
——因为我无意逾越——但身处一段——听起来有点孤独。
Oh, my gosh. It's terrible.
哦，天哪。这太可怕了。
--marriage--
——婚姻中——
Oh, my gosh. It's terrible. Don't make me cry. [LAUGHS] Yes, he's not who I thought he was, or he's becoming somebody that-- yes, it's like I'm not fully who I am with him. And it's sad.
哦，天哪。这太可怕了。别让我哭。[大笑] 是的，他不是我以为的那个人，或者他正在变成某个人，是的，这就像我在他面前不是完全的我。这很可悲。
Yeah. Do you have a-- I don't know-- a plan for if it keeps going down this road, or do you have any red lines? Or you're just hoping, once the election is over, then you can go back to talking about other stuff?
是的。你有什么——我不知道——如果它继续沿着这条路走下去的计划，或者你有什么底线吗？还是你只是在希望，一旦选举结束，那么你就可以回去谈论其他东西了？
Yeah, it sort of steams up and then cools off, steams up and then cools off. Yeah, I probably am not going to do anything. I mean-- I'm on the phone. I'll be done in just five minutes, OK? Yeah, it's not a fun life to talk about Donald Trump. [LAUGHS] I just want to forget about him.
是的，它会升温然后冷却，升温然后冷却。是的，我可能不会做什么。我是说——我在打电话。我马上就讲完了，好吗？是的，谈论唐纳德·特朗普不是一种有趣的生活。[大笑] 我只想忘记他。
Was that your husband who came out just now?
刚才出来的是你丈夫吗？
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。[大笑]
OK. Just, it sounds like you should go?
好的。只是，听起来你该走了？
I should probably wrap it up, yeah.
我大概该收尾了，是的。
OK, well, I'll let you go. I really appreciate you talking.
好的，好吧，我让你走。我真的很感激你的谈话。
Sure, sure. Thank you. It was good to talk with you. Thank you.
当然，当然。谢谢。跟你谈话很高兴。谢谢。
OK.
好的。
All right. Bye.
好吧。再见。
Bye.
再见。
A few days after our call, I got a text from June. She was home from her trip and had gone to vote early with her daughter. She sent me a selfie of the two of them, beaming with their matching voting stickers. They both voted for Kamala.
我们通话几天后，我收到琼的一条短信。她从旅行中回家，并和她的女儿一起提前投票了。她发给我一张她们两人的自拍，带着匹配的投票贴纸眉开眼笑。她们都投了卡玛拉。
June said she felt relieved to have cast her vote, because now, no one could take it away from her. And more than that, she actually feels excited about the prospect of a Harris presidency. She thinks she'll do a good job. After they voted, June and her daughter celebrated, hugged goodbye. And then June peeled her sticker off and went home.
琼说她感到投完票如释重负，因为现在，没人能把它从她手里拿走。更重要的是，她实际上对卡玛拉担任总统的前景感到兴奋。她认为她会做得很好。投票后，琼和她的女儿庆祝、拥抱告别。然后琼撕掉她的贴纸回了家。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our show.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人之一。
OK, so the biggest gap between men and women in this election is with younger voters, people under 30. An NBC News poll found that 59% of young women in that group support Harris, compared to 42% of men, which got us wondering, how is a person that age supposed to find love? Those numbers, if you are straight and under 30 and looking for somebody of the same party, they are not great. And that question brings us to Act Three of our show. Act Three, "Let Me Be Frank."
好的，所以这次选举中男女之间最大的差距是在年轻选民中，也就是30岁以下的人。NBC新闻的一项民调发现，该群体中59%的年轻女性支持哈里斯，而男性为42%。这让我们好奇，那个年龄的人该如何寻找爱情？那些数字，如果你是异性恋且不到30岁，想找同一个党派的人，它们不太好。而这个问题把我们带到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“让我坦率一点”。
So when Aviva DeKornfeld was reaching out to couples looking for people to interview for the story that you just heard, one of the people she came across was a guy named Frank Filocomo. He's trying to navigate his way through the rocky shoals of this gender divide. So she talked to him, too, about what that's like.
所以当阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德在寻找夫妻接受刚才你听到的故事的采访时，她遇到的其中一个人是一个叫弗兰克·菲洛科莫的家伙。他正试图在性别分歧的暗礁中航行。所以她也和他谈了谈那是什么感觉。
Last year, Frank had a date that went exactly the way you hope a first date goes. The conversation felt easy. They made each other laugh. And at the end of the date, they said good night-- no kiss-- Frank doesn't kiss on first dates-- and went home.
去年，弗兰克有一次约会，完全按照你希望第一次约会的样子进行了。交谈感到轻松。他们让对方笑了。在约会结束时，他们说晚安——没有接吻——弗兰克不在第一次约会接吻——然后回家。
And then she was texting me right after the date-- had such a great time. When do we get to do this again? And we're exchanging ideas for what our next date is going to be. And then the morning of the second date, she messages me, and she said, I did some thinking. And I would not like to go out with you again. And--
然后她约会后立刻就发短信给我——度过了愉快的时光。我们什么时候可以再这样做？我们正在交流下一次约会要做什么的意见。然后在第二次约会的早晨，她给我发消息说，我思考了一些事情。我不想再和你出去了。而且——
What do you think is happening when she says that?
当她说这话时，你觉得发生了什么？
Well, I didn't think. I knew what happened.
嗯，我没有想。我知道发生了什么。
Oh. What happened?
哦。发生了什么？
What happened is that I have a very unique Italian last name. If you google me, I come right up. I think I wrote, so you must have looked me up. And she said, yes. And she sent me a screenshot. And I went, ah, got it. [LAUGHS]
发生的是我有一个非常独特的意大利姓氏。如果你谷歌我，我就直接出现了。我想我写了，所以你一定查过我。她说，是的。她发给我一张截图。我心说，啊，明白了。[大笑]
The thing Frank's date had discovered about him-- he's a Republican, voted for Trump twice. The screenshot was of an article he'd written for a conservative magazine.
弗兰克的约会对象关于他发现的事情——他是个共和党人，两次投票给特朗普。那张截图是他为一份保守派杂志写的文章。
Trying to date in deep blue New York City as a registered Republican-- perhaps unsurprisingly, not so easy. He knows better than to lead with his politics. He intentionally leaves it off his dating profile. But even so, sometimes, Frank can't even get past the texting phase and on to the actual date.
在深蓝的纽约市作为注册共和党人约会——也许不足为奇，没那么容易。他知道不要以他的政治观点开头。他故意在约会个人资料上删掉了它。但即使如此，有时，弗兰克甚至无法通过短信阶段进入实际的约会。
A lot of women have said, OK, you seem great, and I'd like to meet you and go on a date. But first, who did you vote for? Or what are your politics?
很多女性说，好的，你看起来不错，我想见你并去约会。但首先，你投给了谁？或者你的政治立场是什么？
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
And then that's when I--
然后就是我——
What do you say?
你说什么？
I say that I'm an independent thinker. And--
我说我是一个独立的思考者。而且——
[LAUGHS] That's really coded as right-wing.
[大笑] 那真的被编码为右翼。
Exactly. And--
完全正确。而且——
You might as well just say, I voted for Donald Trump.
你不如直接说，我投票给唐纳德·特朗普。
Yeah, and I have.
是的，而且我确实投了。
And then what do they say?
然后她们说什么？
They say, well, I can't do it. Can't do it.
她们说，嗯，我做不到。做不到。
By Frank's estimate, 40 to 50 women have canceled their dates with him upon discovering his politics. Having been born and raised in Brooklyn, Frank has this sort of odd problem on his hands, because he basically fits in, unless he's talking.
根据弗兰克的估计，有40到50名女性在发现他的政治立场后取消了与他的约会。由于在布鲁克林出生和长大，弗兰克手头上有这样一个奇怪的问题，因为他基本上融入其中，除非他在说话。
Everyone I've ever met has told me that they think I'm some Bernie progressive. I strike people as being left-wing.
我见过的每个人都告诉我，他们以为我是某个伯尼进步派。我给人的印象是左翼。
Yeah. Well, you live in Brooklyn. And you have little glasses, so.
是的。嗯，你住在布鲁克林。而且你戴着小眼镜，所以。
I have little glasses and holes in my ears.
我有小眼镜和耳朵上的洞。
He used to have gauges. He also has a bunch of tattoos. He's a real mix of things. He's got some punk in him. But he's also nerdy, casually says words like "verklempt" and "pugilistic." But you can't see any of his edge today. Came straight from his job at a right-wing nonprofit, so he's in his full conservative drag-- suit, tie, token fun socks.
他过去有耳扩。他还有一堆纹身。他是各种事物的真实混合体。他身上有点朋克。但他也像个书呆子，随口说出“ verklempt”（情绪激动）和“ pugilistic”（好斗的）这样的词。但你今天看不出他的任何锋芒。直接从他在一家右翼非营利组织的工作过来，所以他穿着全套保守派行头——西装、领带、标志性的趣味袜子。
Frank's been a conservative since he was little. He grew up in a right-leaning household and proudly wore a McCain-Palin button on his backpack at school when he was 11. The main thing that makes Frank a conservative these days, he says, is that national sovereignty is extremely important to him, meaning he thinks we should close the border, build a wall if we need to, anything to discourage undocumented immigrants from coming here.
弗兰克从小就是保守派。他在一个倾向于右翼的家庭长大，11岁时在学校里自豪地在背包上戴着麦凯恩-佩林的纽扣。他说，弗兰克这些天成为保守派的主要原因是国家主权对他极其重要，这意味着他认为我们应该关闭边境，如果有需要就修墙，任何东西以阻止非法移民来到这里。
Otherwise, basically, he's one of those fiscally conservative, socially liberal guys. But his dates mostly care about that conservative part. He remembers this one first date that really kind of stung because he was particularly excited about her. They were at a bar, bantering back and forth.
否则，基本上，他是那种财政上保守、社会上自由的家伙。但他的约会对象大多关心那个保守的部分。他记得这次真正有点刺痛的第一次约会，因为他特别为她兴奋。他们在酒吧里，来回开玩笑。
And then she said, so what do you do for work? And there's kind of no way around that, you know? I could be super ambiguous and say, oh, I work for a nonprofit.
然后她说，所以你工作做什么？绕开这一点根本没门，你知道吗？我可以超级含糊其辞说，哦，我在一家非营利组织工作。
Yeah.
是的。
But then that lends itself to, OK, well, which nonprofit?
但那容易导向，好的，嗯，哪个非营利组织？
Yeah, that can mean anything.
是的，那意味着什么。
Right.
没错。
Frank told her he worked for a branch of the famously conservative outlet The National Review, where he occasionally writes. His date thought he meant The Nation, which is kind of the opposite.
弗兰克告诉她，他在著名的保守派媒体《国家评论》的一个分支工作，他偶尔在那里写文章。他的约会对象以为他指的是《国家杂志》，那基本上是相反的。
And then I clarified, no, a little different.
然后我澄清了，不，有点不同。
How would you describe the difference?
你如何描述这种区别？
I said we're more on the right, [CHUCKLES] which is my euphemistic way of saying we're conservative, because we are. And I said that. And immediately, her whole demeanor changed.
我说我们在右翼更多，[轻笑] 这是我委婉的说法，意思是保守派，因为我们是。我说了那话。立刻，她的整个举止都变了。
Like, what? She leans back in her chair or something?
比如，什么？她向后靠在椅子上还是什么的？
Yeah. Yup, yup. Body language changed. And she said, well, so you're a conservative.
是的。是的，是的。肢体语言变了。她说，嗯，所以你是个保守派。
They were only 20 minutes into the date and decided to call it a night.
他们约会才20分钟就决定在那天晚上结束。
I actually planned on walking her out or walking her to the train station. And so I said, OK, let me get the bill. And I go up to the bar to get the bill. And then I came back, and she was gone.
我实际上计划送她走或者送她去火车站。所以我说，好的，让我结账。我走到吧台结账。然后我回来时，她走了。
Frank thought maybe she'd gone to the bathroom. But his date had scooted to the bar and arrived with a helmet. Frank noticed the helmet was also gone.
弗兰克以为也许她去了厕所。但他的约会对象溜到了吧台，拿着头盔。弗兰克注意到头盔也不见了。
I'm thinking, I don't think she took her helmet to the bathroom. But I said, let me give it a few minutes, you know. And I gave it a few minutes, and I said, she left.
我在想，我不觉得她带了头盔去厕所。但我说，让我给几分钟时间，你知道。我给了几分钟时间，我说，她走了。
It does hurt. And when I say this to people, I don't mean to make it into a pity thing. It's not like this is being-- conservative is some immutable characteristic, right? I don't want people to feel bad for me. But it does hurt, because to me, it's like, who am I? So I'm 27. After 27 years of existence, if my identity boils down to being a conservative and a registered Republican, then that's a sad 27 years that I've lived. That's really sad.
这确实很伤人。当我告诉人们这件事时，我不打算把它变成讨人怜悯的事情。保守不是某种不可改变的特征，对吧？我不希望人们为我感到难过。但这确实很伤人，因为对我来说，就像，我是谁？所以我是27岁。在27年的存在之后，如果我的身份归结为是一个保守派和一个注册共和党人，那真是一个可悲的27年我活过了。那真的很可悲。
Frank's a registered Republican. But to him, that's the least interesting thing about him. Here are some things that Frank would like people to know about him. He plays jazz guitar. He has a very old cat, 17 years old, who is still in remarkably good health. He's also obsessed with aquariums. He has four of them in his studio apartment.
弗兰克是注册共和党人。但对他来说，那是关于他最不有趣的事情。以下是弗兰克希望人们知道的关于他的一些事情。他弹爵士吉他。他有一只非常老、17岁的猫，健康状况仍然非常好。他还痴迷于水族馆。他在他的单间公寓里有四个。
The stuff that Frank thinks should matter is the way you comport yourself in the world. Are you polite to wait staff? Do you hold the door for people? Do you check in on your friends when they're sick? Most of a relationship, he says, is not about politics. And so he wants the women he dates to see those other parts of him, not be blinded by his party affiliation.
弗兰克认为应该重要的事情是你在这个世界上对待自己的方式。你对服务人员有礼貌吗？你为人们扶门吗？你检查朋友们是否生病了？他说，关系的大部分与政治无关。所以他希望他约会的女性看到他的那些其他部分，而不是被他的政党倾向所蒙蔽。
So he's tried various tactics over the years to get around it-- downplaying, addressing it head on and making a case for himself. Once, since women kept googling him and finding his writing, he even gave a fake last name.
所以他多年来尝试了各种战术来绕过它——淡化、直接解决并为自己辩护。有一次，因为女性不断谷歌他并找到他的写作，他甚至给了假姓氏。
But that made me feel terrible about myself.
但这让我对自己感到很糟糕。
So it wasn't worth doing that?
所以那样做不值得？
Yeah, that's no way to go through life.
是的，那根本不是度过一生。
I asked Frank, why not just date conservative women? He insisted the conservative dating pool in New York City is simply too small. There's a filter on the dating app Hinge that you can pay for that does let you filter for political preference. He did try that once.
我问弗兰克，为什么不直接和保守派女性约会？他坚持认为纽约市的保守派约会池实在太小。在约会应用Hinge上有一个你可以付费的过滤器，确实让你过滤政治偏好。他有一次确实尝试了。
And I realized that it was meaningless, you know?
然后我意识到那是毫无意义的，你知道？
Hmm.
嗯。
I'm attracted to people for other reasons. In fact, I would put politics probably at the end.
我被人们吸引是出于其他原因。实际上，我会把政治大概放在最后。
What?
什么？
Yeah.
是的。
That's crazy!
那太疯狂了！
Why is that crazy?
为什么那很疯狂？
Because the thing that should be at the end is, like, "my favorite color is green."
因为应该在最后的事情是，比如，“我最喜欢的颜色是绿色。”
That's more important.
那个更重要。
No, it's not.
不，它不是。
It absolutely is more important.
它绝对更重要。
Why?
为什么？
Well, I'm tempted to push it back on you and say, why is politics important? It's not important. I don't think so at all, actually.
嗯，我很想把它推回给你并说，为什么政治很重要？它根本不重要，实际上我完全不这么认为。
Yeah, but do you think that politics is less important to you because some of the policies that you might be voting for directly impact you in a less personal way than they impact the women that you want to date?
是的，但你认为政治对你来说不那么重要，是因为你可能投票支持的一些政策，比它们影响你想要约会的女性，以一种较少个人的方式影响你吗？
Oh, maybe. I think that's part of it. And I have a lot of empathy for people who are impacted more directly. But I think that I look at my day-to-day life, and I'll walk through a door and someone-- or I'll hold the door for someone, and they'll walk through and they won't say thank you. And I go, what was that? What was that about? It's stuff like that, little interpersonal interactions, that mean something to me, you know? Or--
哦，也许吧。我想那是部分原因。而且我对那些受影响更直接的人有很多同理心。但我认为我观察我的日常生活中，我会穿过一扇门，有人——或者我为某人扶门，他们穿过却没有说谢谢。我就想，那是什么？那是关于什么的？正是类似的东西，小小的个人互动，对我意味着什么，你知道吗？或者——
But to you, but not to the people that you're dating. I'm sure the women you're dating would be much-- it's much more important to them to be able to get an abortion than have a door held for them.
但是对你，而不是对你约会的人。我确信你约会的女性会——能够堕胎对她们来说比有人扶门重要得多。
Oh, sure. But I'm one out of 340 million people. I'm not effectuating policy or something.
哦，当然。但我是3.4亿人中的一个。我不是在执行政策什么的。
I can see why his dates don't see it that way.
我能理解为什么他的约会对象不那样看它。
I have some news to end this story with, which is that, after dozens of dates, Frank is actually seeing someone. It's new, but it seems to be going well. She's a lefty, and she knows all about his views. Politics actually came up on their first date.
我有关于这个故事的结尾的一些新闻，那就是，在几十次约会后，弗兰克实际上正在见某个人。这是新的，但似乎进行得很顺利。她是左派，她知道他的所有观点。政治实际上在他们的第一次约会就出现了。
It's been a few months now, and they've had a lot of conversations about politics. Frank told me his girlfriend's voting for Kamala Harris. And the idea that Frank might vote for Trump, that really, really bothers her. Recently, with the election coming up, they had one particularly hard conversation about it.
已经几个月了，他们进行了很多关于政治的谈话。弗兰克告诉我他的女朋友要投卡玛拉·哈里斯。而且弗兰克可能投票给特朗普的想法，那确实，真的困扰她。最近，随着选举临近，他们进行了一次特别艰难的谈话。
She said, we care for each other, and we obviously enjoy being around each other. And we have, for the past four or five months, however long it's been. And I don't think-- she said that she doesn't think it's a deal-breaker for her, but it's something that concerns her, you know? And I don't take that lightly. So it's made me do a lot of thinking.
她说，我们关心彼此，而且我们显然喜欢在一起。而且我们有，过去四五个月，无论它有多久。我不觉得——她说她不认为对他来说这是交易破坏者，但这确实是她担心的东西，你知道？我不轻视它。所以它让我做了很多思考。
And what'd you say?
你说了什么？
I said that I want you to know that I hear you. It was emotional. I think we were both a little verklempt.
我说我想要你知道我听到了你的话。这很感性。我想我们俩都有一点 verklempt。
His girlfriend kept saying, Trump's a rapist. You've got to vote for the whole person, not just the policies you like. These conversations with his girlfriend and other people have actually moved him. And so Frank is thinking of voting third party this election, which may have more meaning in his relationship than it does for our country, thanks to the fucking electoral college. Like most of us, Frank doesn't live in a swing state.
他的女朋友不断说，特朗普是强奸犯。你必须投票给整个人，而不是仅仅是你喜欢的政策。这些与他女朋友和其他人的交谈实际上感动了他。所以弗兰克正在考虑在这次选举投第三方，这在他关系中可能比对我们国家更有意义，多亏了那该死的选举人团。像我们大多数人一样，弗兰克不住在摇摆州。
Aviva DeKornfeld. We first heard about Frank in a story in The Guardian.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德。我们第一次听到关于弗兰克是在《卫报》的一个故事里。
["VOTE!" BY THE LINDA LINDAS]
Well, our program was produced today by Bim Adewunmi. The people who put together today's show include Jendayi Bonds, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
好吧，我们的节目今天由 Bim Adewunmi 制作。组建今天节目的成员包括 Jendayi Bonds, Zoe Chace, Michael Comite, Henry Larson, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, 以及 Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的主编是 Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是 David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是 Emanuele Berry。This American Life 由 PRX，公共广播交流中心交付给公共广播电台。
Just a heads-up to our Life Partners, there is a new bonus episode this week that's out that you will find in your feed. Everybody else, if you want to sign up and get this bonus content and other stuff, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. Thanks this week to Life Partners Kelly Darnell, Ken Erwin, Lauren Cahill Fitzsimmons, Lawrence Lin, Rob Nero, Laurel Paul, and Jeanie Thomas. Thank you, guys.
给我们的生活伴侣（Life Partners）一个提醒，本周有一个新的奖励剧集出来了，你可以在你的源里找到。其他人，如果你想注册并获得这个奖励内容和其他东西，去 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。本周感谢生活伴侣 Kelly Darnell, Ken Erwin, Lauren Cahill Fitzsimmons, Lawrence Lin, Rob Nero, Laurel Paul, 以及 Jeanie Thomas。谢谢你们。
Thanks, as always, to our program's confounder, Mr. Torey Malatia-- always comparing himself to Mr. Potato Head.
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的创始人，Torey Malatia 先生——总是把自己和土豆头先生作比较。
I have little glasses and holes in my ears.
我有小眼镜和耳朵上的洞。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多 This American Life 的故事。
["VOTE!" BY THE LINDA LINDAS]